[Music]
last week it seems like yesterday but
last week uh
we uh we're taking a look back at you
know 20 years and it occurs to me that
you came on the late night show
many many many many many many times
you're a good friend to us yes always
funny always a terrific guest
now you've moved to la like yes do you
are you a happier person in la or are
you less happy well let's not go crazy i
um
look la's beautiful i'm sure you found
it beautiful but sadly the only real
problem with la
and it's sort of a hackneyed problem but
it's a very real problem is i know that
if i get into my car within 20 minutes
i'll be furious
doesn't matter where i'm going what time
of day it is what day it is if i get
into my car within 20 minutes
i'll be in my car another car will pull
up beside me and they'll see me alone in
my car going
and i imagine one of them will turn to
the other and say god what's that guy
mad about and the other person will say
like i don't know but it happened a long
time ago i think
that is not anger-related traffic stuff
that's the mommy and daddy stuff he's
working out in there so you find you get
in your car and it becomes a rage zone
for you i think not just a rage zone
it's a rage sanctuary
it's a place where you feel safe well if
you think about how chipper people are
in la and how they
la is known for people being very happy
it's really because we have cathartic
events of rage and anger in our cars
so when you get out of your car you're
like god i feel great you know i think i
really shook something loose there you
know what i mean yes repressed memories
i like my dad again you know that kind
of thing
so wherever you go you go to the you go
anywhere you go on any errand you get
out of your car and you've vented it all
in your car that's very nice oh
absolutely and the only problem with it
really uh with traffic is that when you
know you're going to invest time in it
whether you want to or not
and the worst thing about traffic is
when it just dissipates for no reason
where you've spent 20 minutes and then
it just kind of breaks up and there's
nothing there you're like that was about
nothing right nothing right like i'm not
saying i want to see a dead guy you know
but
but i'd like to see a screwed up car and
an aggravated man right
like you want to see like at least a
downed some if you're waiting like for
two hours there should be a downed
helicopter right something well that's
very exciting yeah yeah but when there's
oranges that's what i'm always dreaming
what a [ __ ] load of oranges that would
say california to me
a highway littered with citrus so that
so you fantasize about that oh yeah man
i've been in traffic for 20 minutes
oranges would be great just
yeah exactly that's tremendous yeah
goats should be good too but that's
ghost that's more happening we actually
drive back in time for that
you have to be an ancient tuscany for
that there's the roman coliseum still
functioning